back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
but can you always look like a real love
bird I feel life thank you
real Korean angel you know yeah but you
in walk around with all this swag cuz
this boy when every goddamn Award for
parasite did you guys win parasite yeah
we want and what's it about that virus
it's not about the VIPRE corona virus in
it oh just watch the movie you have to
watch the movie you understand how a
parasite works and that's kind of what
the movie does oh and I heard someone
said you have to read the movie that's
true you do have to read subtitles but
you'll be lost in it it'll it'll be
amazing trust me how much is it to get
like a Korean gotta sit there and tell
you what's hands later really Green is
terrible and my English is not that
great either yeah just get Bobby Lee
what's up just get Bobby yeah yeah Bobby
hidden speak Korean yeah yeah you see
what the heck bro yeah he speaks it
visually Korean happy Valentine's Day
happy Valentine's Day dawg good to see
you today man yeah man Nick went all out
with the studio here he's beautiful
no you dude Russell Stover nothing says
I love you like a box of cheap-ass
chocolates wrong mean those are good do
you like them that's the best chocolate
399 can buy baby that's right dog yeah
are you getting your girl something I
yeah I'm gonna have to cuz she actually
was here last night helping me decorate
Wow what does she want some chocolate
some are oh I love how Brendan says we
probably won't eat something so we
probably won't eat okay like anybody's
ever believe that when you said that man
dude Valentine's Day a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] must be real man it's a made-up
holiday from Hallmark nah man it's for
love dude yeah oh yeah do you own - get
a tortoise open day yeah you trying to
get this episode off correct you know
I'm trying to clog my heart with
chocolate but we have other recalls or
horror loggers that
helicopter want to introduce your
buddies people wanna be like damn
[ __ ] cat really change it up you
lookin like cat has the coronavirus okay
cat grew a beard and looks like she
sucks [ __ ] fish taco or just even be
sad introduce yourselves man oh man well
we got no right that man oh come on the
day of love I wanted to do the day man
okay what's up I'm Craig Craig Craig
calm sea sea dog I just did that now
that's Craig that Chappell
okay [ __ ] beast comics it's so
culture cuz when I said I said we should
have Craig on yeah cuz he goes we need a
Mexican I said dude I saw Craig said
he's hilarious thank you buddy
and then I said two minutes ago he goes
oh yeah I know Craig I said he goes dude
how much simply be his name's Craig
Franken and he said hey man you gotta
have great we'll have Craig on him like
I don't know Craig so I'm whitewashed
yeah are you really yeah
what percent Mexican are you I'm half
hell yeah yeah my mom's full Mexican my
dad's widest [ __ ] and where'd they meet
a high school Oh yar bonsai in Harbor
City or La Mina oh no Mexicans love high
school dude no high school sweethearts
oh yeah are they still together
no of course now mine it's America yeah
you right oh yeah
and then put the fans no Chapelle for it
and here's Craig right here actually
appearing on a yeah
MTV's next we have yeah let's see this I
see him oh that's you Craig yeah
[Music]
okay nice to meet you nice to meet you
cool
one this first race here now it's time
to switch it up a little bit I'm gonna
take you to a surprise all right
[Music]
like a handsome twin bro watch that what
happened on the date I won know what him
uh we she kneed me in the nuts and we
kissed and then he said you want the
money or the girl and I was like I want
the money I move and then he he said
she's the girl cuz it looks better for
TV and I was like what I want though and
then he's like just choose the girl give
you both and I actually got both you did
yeah and who was the girl what was her
name Brittany oh wow what do you mean
you got both like did you guys hang out
after the would that show that what was
so confusing I thought that though I
thought it was gonna be like a whole
nother date set up by MTV and then I
wouldn't it wrapped I was like what's up
and they're like go get her number I was
like that's it that's all it was like
you doing that show was fun though in
tease next yeah I was young it was a
good show I like to eliminate we also
got Chappelle lacy are coming back man
thanks for coming back Chappelle thanks
for having me back on the game show or
not no do I look like I play games oh my
god what America's strongest
cheerleaders do what about that new so
cheer are you watching that I haven't
seen it yet you're gonna love it but I
am excited that people are getting a new
understanding of cheer yeah you're gonna
love it dude oh yeah I think that's
funny all right I know you got that good
Matt talk Chappelle were you want really
the guy like yeah I was I was very
difficult to do to cheer with because I
was just like oh yeah an ego yeah no I
don't have an ego I'm just like an ego
you can you can [ __ ] up around me you
standard yeah oh you're just like this
one kid on the episode there's a dude
like that he's super athletic and
talented yeah that was like girls mess
up over I would go crazy hit some
off-camera I did not do that should
probably just be hanging out and just
have people to show up at cheer practice
with a couple people those chicks stand
pacing on his shoulder ready
you'll love it though you should yeah
yeah well look we got some culture here
today man and you guys are representing
a couple different cultures and we're
happy to have you guys here today
thank you guys for being here feel free
to just be a part of the show man chime
in
Nick looking extra freaking extra extra
birdy today
I like being festive and because it's
Valentine's Day we've got relationship
advice for the first time in weeks
yeah some people in damn you I know what
are we gonna do man really shits falling
apart bring back Nick looks like he got
bit by a big pigeon that Street picture
shoot people the coronavirus first
relationship advice we got max from
Nebraska all right give it to us maxi
and masculine arouse God been with my
boyfriend for a year and I'm so broke so
broke what should I do
for Valentine's Day
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young great
brows he mentioned in the emails that
his boyfriend that loves Valentine's Day
- it's his favorite holidays
oh that's frustrating what a shock how
do you come on that broke hot Valentine
is he that broke because he got a name
tag didn't work he's doing this Tamara
branch a pole a that's a Chipotle badge
is it Panera Panera Bread you could cut
uh you know you could carve a heart or
something I mean you know a hard on the
back again yeah get creative with it you
don't have to go all out get your girl
like a your man like a Gucci bag or
something like that but I wonder about
Valentine's Days about bro yeah you
could steal stuff you could yeah you
could you could get creative at home you
don't decorate some shooting box bro
your panini in a box
decorate your butt you get a spray tan
with a heart around your booty I don't
know what's happening man I think my
buddy's growing squad stuff huh no I
mean sometimes I'll drop something to
get it but I might be enough for you
though you know that might be enough
good I'm afraid even pick anything up
anymore I need to get a doll to just
lift stuff up to me because I can't if I
do anything a lift and dog my bus is
gonna take over no genes yeah we're
genius you know I'm thinking about
getting four faces chiseled in one of my
ass cheeks whose face is getting big
thank you yeah black and you probably
say sour shabbos new thing boy talk
what's so Doug Doug black in me I don't
know I think I definitely had to work
outdoors a lot I'll put it like okay I
guess back in the day like my one of my
grandparents did I think we definitely
you know I just feel like somebody
[ __ ] a burro or something yeah you
know cuz I feel like we could be cousins
cuz you got an ask you got an ass on the
back yeah on the back you're like damn
whoo
a little fun damn look at these two
little Buster's he's do thick it's hard
having a big butt because it makes the
rest your body look like it's leaning
forward that's what I don't like but he
gives you good posture oh it's kind of
like this you got that Nicki Minaj bro I
didn't know either two fans like dude
yeah check out those cheeks I'm like
Zoey's I'm number oh hi mam yeah with
what's gonna she who knows do you always
cover them up on stage what do you think
I like these [ __ ] coats on these
trench coats and [ __ ] oh let the cheeks
breathe I told you this man bro I wanna
breathe man and they're hot - they make
my whole body hot new Chozen why they
retain heat hey JB but retains heat now
yeah when you go to Hawaii bronze and
buns bro on the beach yeah a little
thong on bronze a mob dogs might get out
there a little yeah post the picture
we'll see how it goes I don't know about
that yo man one thing health experts
dieticians are you yelling at me man you
locked up on something I am you notice
my energy yeah talk about athletic
greens an ID your voice even sounds
athletic dude and I do I look a little
shade of green
you do look green all right green that's
how good it is dude they're talking
about an ultimate daily all-in-one
health drink bro 75 vitamins and
minerals I know we doing I mean that
they had that many dude me neither
remember I remember I had to take
vitamin A vitamin B vitamin D vitamin M
dude bunch of pills next thing you know
do my French choked on one of my
vitamins watch not anymore dude no this
is a drink easy to drink delivered in
powder form and mixed with water it's so
dang easy oh it's your own little
breaking bad at home but it's breaking
better you're breaking yourself in a
feeling better imagine not feeling good
now imagine feeling better boy that is
athletic greens you get the powder you
put it together in the morning it comes
in this beautiful little kit it's a
great gift I'm sending it to my mother
Oh your mom's gonna love that she loves
I wake every morning right down the
hatches and then ready to start my day
I love that man dude get greener get
greener whether you're taking steps
towards a healthier lifestyle or you've
been an athlete pushing for better
performance athletic greens takes the
guesswork out of everyday good health
I'm not joking
it does right up top boom hit it and
you're not thinking all day oh do I need
to care it do I need a cabbage don't you
swallow this head of lettuce
jump over to athletic greens dot-com / K
80s and claim our special offer today
tell them about the offer B oh man this
off is so fun dude 20 free travel packs
value at $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic greens dot-com / K 80s
yep athletic greens calm / K 80s man I
get worried at night do it you know I
started following what's that website at
some for one month citizen citizen or
something citizen sorry yeah yeah man
there's a lot of there's a lot of crime
going on around the hood and times are
changing man you see now people need to
take crime prevention into their own
hands I want to know if somebody's
outside somebody's stealing my tour I
want to know if somebody's you know
selling seashells down by the seashore
you right man and you need simply safe
home security that's what you need
there's a break-in simply safe uses real
video evidence to give the police an
eyewitness account of the crime mm-hmm
that means police dispatch up to 350
percent faster than a normal burglar
alarm dude if there's our common dude
fool they're coming and if there's a
break-in I usually break out I get
nervous I get acne if there's crime yeah
but simply say protect your home from
fires fires bro dude water damage carbon
monoxide the silent assassin not so
silent anymore safe its 24-hour
seven-day-a-week monitoring by live
security professional no tools needed
it's 50 cents a day with no contracts
hot are we doing and be safe out there
visit simply safecom / k 80s you get
free shipping and a 60 day risk-free
trial you've got nothing to lose
that's right you don't need to be
looking at your property all day some
other Muppet can do it and that
beautiful Muppet is simply safe go now
and be sure go to simply safe dot-com /
k 80s so they know our show sent you
dude Valentine's man what are you doing
for Valentine's working are you yeah
working we're at Ontario improv you can
be honest we can you know says I love
you like seeing my big ass son it's
bring the girls bring your diet everyone
bring you boys can bro
wait yeah what if I started give to a
gay man if he was trying to make his man
happy you know for cheap for cheap dude
I just
what's that cheap happiness mmm not
cheap happiness go on a hike on top of
the hike you suck your man off behind
the bushes dude every man would love
that that's what I'm saying
special though it's not just like oh
you're not doing that every day you're
not you know yeah well they might
everything what gay culture do not too
much like if you took my Runyon Canyon
it was like oh we made it and then BOOM
yeah like definitely costs anything but
little effort and a positive attitude
dude yeah you ain't the adrenaline rush
yeah yeah nothing better and maybe get
some spray get like a little bit of
limit or like a hairspray or grapefruit
spray you put it on his wiener yeah
maybe even like yeah a little Irish
butter a little Mesquite on the bottom
of it
yeah ugh dude that's crazy man how do
you sauce your nuts
I'm just trying to think if I went on
hike yeah I guess you could just look
but then your buddy has to be all tired
and walk back down the height yeah I
guess those queasy legs yeah you don't
be carrying your buddy down oh you do
yeah that's part of the carry you down
jump on me yeah suck you off carry it
down baby
yes dope that's crazy man it would be a
big boy though yeah they'd be tough for
me to carry that guy probably dates a
big man though yeah cuz I think you guys
might know better because I would
consider him probably a twink is that
right I think he's a little hairless and
then my comic is it a cub or
honor I think I don't know it sounds
like you know more all this term there
I'm a bit I know I'm not a bit on
because I'm not hearing what does that
remember chin we figured out one day
she's like no it's an otter for sure no
chins on honor chin just looks like an
otter look at chin yeah little bit up an
otter can we get an otter up there
please no don't it yeah dude
do your eyes know how to [ __ ] look
around oh it's chin I don't think a
little bit like an otter
oh I feel you beautiful a little bit
yeah nice otter on you look at a mean
one right there at bottom lab can you
google otter fights there's definitely
some good otter if I taste to watch
using my car go wide other fights that
ain't real water fight so you don't
think they fight what do they do all day
nothing I'll just be fighting over over
wood right it's like it's a turf war of
otters mm-hmm and looking cute other
otters show up looking cute yeah we got
a lot of otters there's other animals
but no otter on otter crime well they'd
be hoping to get that did that outer
just dump okay dude sea otter versus
giant otter oh this is just I'm gonna go
back to the otter dunking please the
modders are gay Hey
all right you know what homeboy should
do with his boyfriend dude let give him
a Hall Pass for Valentine's Day
mmm give him a Hall Pass let him take
someone else for a ride that's not a bad
idea not about it it's very cheap it is
cheap yeah let somebody else deal with
your man night I just might have one
night come back tomorrow pause about two
was forget it ever happened
wow that's love dude I wonder if he
would do that would they do that in the
eye and the cultural community guys what
do y'all think no medicines for sure not
know how no black people I don't think
so really
don't cry on that that's more of a white
thing yeah the black guy is usually the
third from what I yeah the boy were like
yeah now you're talking about black is
that your toy you're talking about a
porno kind of situation [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's definitely a white boy like
that's like a white married kind of yeah
it's like uber but for Weiner yeah there
you go
uber but for we he could do it he could
do that for his man it smells like what
are you kidding me good Chapelle in man
smell shots up hard pass Farva some
jorts and a possibility you gotta get in
valentine's day if you ain't banging
dudes bro if you're ready to bang some
little dude who works at the freakin
Chipotle Panera Bread yeah here we got a
question that came in right here let's
get to somebody
we got another relationship advice
question - shirt swaggy so Theo Brendan
the relationship advice for you I'm in
college and I've been in a class with
this chick they're sort of like we've
been talking back and forth for a while
when like the same group work on
projects and [ __ ] and it was last
semester this masters same field so
we're in every class basically together
moving forward I was wondering she's
probably basically I know whether I pull
the trigger and like make a move and say
like an obvious like hey I like kind of
like you thing or hold off is what I
have been doing just because I feel like
it would be awkward going forward if she
were to I don't say no so which might
just be me being a [ __ ] or there's a
wreath at real like going forward I'd
have to go the whole rest of my college
career that's good
if anybody knows about being a [ __ ]
it's ya boy let me tell you this man
here's the thing you can admire her from
afar and just have her be that kind of
special thing that you look at and
in your head what could happen if you
took the chance there's some value in
that of never knowing not really there's
a little bit broken gret dude okay
there's a right that's the only value
but there's also the fact it could
happen that but it could have my brain
oh that might be wifey but now that's
the other side of the coin beside the
coin what is it he should hit her up but
you don't need like hey let's go out to
dinner tonight that's awkward
you met Caitlyn after this maybe let's
go get a drink after the study or some
you build a few wreaths of room bro read
the room dude he's been reading the room
credit also what college where you
there's always projects but I don't
[ __ ] project a bit college but
anyways just do you just that's weird I
don't know what major yes but other
projects on the football team that's now
there's projects but play stuff you
wouldn't like um you gotta shoot your
shot man shooter shoot but how do you do
it he's a classroom what do you guys do
ethnically would be neither intern I
wrote a love album for a girl why ya
like me why you gotta say mixtape brick
yeah what is that what is that not I
made an album Brooke made it herself
yeah so a blanket car bro yeah do you
still have that tape by Chen yeah I got
it back because you made fun of me about
it shoes I hate the music appreciate the
effort
you don't think my boy has a cell for
SoundCloud hey what they were all in 16
they were all eight songs Wonderwall
hope you know was a Jew dropping a hot
20 on a girl no I was that drunk yeah it
was like eight songs though one rap song
any of it I just remember the chorus
how'd it go
I wonder why she gave it back no she
didn't want to give it back but I was
like yo you didn't like it you made fun
of me about it
give me the [ __ ] back you never gave her
a chance to like it that do you thank
you I did did you all my friends would
tell me about they're like oh she's
making fun of your album I'm like really
yeah then I got a bad she Ebadi now I
can't remember it I don't like to talk
about it yeah a white girl no she's not
white it was a a chin she's Korean yeah
hey you gave a mixed rap CD to a Korean
girl and yeah no [ __ ] she didn't like
never jacket yeah it was one rap song
what was the rest of the songs it was
just me playing acoustic guitar I wrote
I wrote a poem on the topic I wrote this
poem in school yeah tight like four
grade the words who fly the earth and
how are you I was like 16 so a
six-year-old want to hear your guitar
photos a little rip so what inspired it
I wrote this poem obviously I like to
but I wrote this poem in class look we
had to write these poems and I got an F
on it and I was like watch this teacher
I'm gonna show you that this poem
actually means something so that's what
made me write the album so I took the
poem like the ja Rule by Ohio way this
sound like the first of all John Mayer
had me hype in the early 2000s I damned
this is I can do it I can do it and yeah
and gave you hope yeah my went to my
boys house this was like when the Mac
first came out and then he had a red
light outside his door so his mom knew
not to come in because we were we were
dropping hitch we were dropping hits a
real black dudes were actually out
dropping their
he's like man Oh
turn turn up that wailing ginger yeah
shout out to wailing Jean enjoy at all
don't come back next week unless you got
that mixtape
okay I can't let the world hear that cha
ching ching boys ladies with Jim what
are you doing for Valentine's Day we're
probably going to your show on 7:30 dope
on Friday again I if you want all single
you guys out I'll get the spotlight on
you and I'll I'll make sure you do
whatever you think feels right play some
of us repels hits oh yeah I'll bring my
do it live I don't know but you guys
would have some ideas for me but now all
like you guys have given me is bring
Chappelle for my lady
well next rows Polynesian Vietnamese
Vietnamese and it's not cat it's not cat
mm-hm Craig do you have a girl yeah oh
you do yeah serious girlfriend and there
he is right here let's moving on to your
girls guts why tits
bro I'll say that all right it's that a
gun yeah what's up Kingston this is Alex
from Houston Texas
I got a key understand for you believing
your girl when she says oh you don't
have to do anything for me in
Valentine's Day it's just a Hallmark
holiday personally I believe it's a trap
why because the next time she goes to
work goes out with her friends shows up
at church everybody in the world is
gonna ask her what did Alex do for you
and Valentine's Day and guess how she's
gonna have to answer nothing
Alex did jack [ __ ] for me on Valentine's
Day and then what happened absolutely
chaos ensues at home anyway guys theater
stinging gang gang
buzz buzz oh wow what the for mass
shooter he's a zebra a no-match it was
just one was this one mm-hmm
in Thailand nope oh crap there's one
time where's the other one the other one
was a Korean guy way back yeah remember
yeah yes
all right you're right ring is dirty
Mexican mass shooters or not what did
you go oh wait I guess you guys have
Muslims it's cartels yeah decapitation
whatever you can hit with 12 bullets two
pistols yeah Yosemite or Yosemite Sam
was basically the first use man yeah he
had a man he was a ginger maxium from
from Guadalajara yeah yeah he was like a
Canelo dude I know guys I'm with a
Sinaloa zoo remember those guys almost
got me into that oh yeah I remember was
getting best too yeah we also went down
a weird road to save that money boy say
4200 though yeah they set the whole
place on fire apparently you get a lot
of bad investment opportunity I didn't
hear my questions either I don't think
he asked a question everybody was
distracted he basically said what
Brendan that he thinks Valentine's is
made-up holiday so what do you think
when your girl agrees not to do anything
on Valentine's Day do you King that or
is she setting a trap well it's her
chicken had friends like girl I told you
[ __ ] lazy he ain't doing [ __ ] so
y'all worry about her chicken ass
friends you know I'm saying yeah but
maybe be like eight so if you're trying
to get dinner on Friday night
everyone's packed right so [ __ ] that
noise just like we'll go next week just
add a little next week I don't like that
idea
what do you got here Craig Mexican Craig
yes celebrate celebrate early on or
later yeah he already has seven goes in
front of him he's also you think about
doing something obviously whether it's
for Valentine's Day or not he wants to
do some take you shoot clay ducks yeah
there you go
they'll be fun that's a good man yeah
take a girl shooting could be fun um ah
dude I'm pretty nice
that's a true few say let's do something
a different day cuz it's like saying hey
I don't want to take responsibility on
this day I feel like that's as much of a
trap I'm not saying you you particularly
but I'm just saying like Oh we'll do
something in April like between doing
[ __ ] and April the girls thinking yeah I
know if we don't do some of them
Valentines and we doing something you
know unless she has to work then I think
you can get out of it it's not such a
put so much pressure on dudes done dick
girls don't have to do [ __ ] but dude the
other that's more of a holiday for them
the other 364 days you live to care
about your girl that's pretty easy super
birthday yeah that's two 363 days
Christmas Thanksgiving around 61 no no
62 year right now Thanksgiving 362 it is
me time yeah do this so not bad they're
asking for one day they want some
chocolate okay okay okay
[Laughter]
yeah
you understand
just now hotel yeah downtown ye like
rose petals out and [ __ ] you know you're
so right about that [ __ ] like they set
you up because she was like last year
because this is my first girlfriend ever
last year
yeah yeah but last year she was like
yeah we don't need to get each other
anything and then she got me something
and that was like huh and I didn't get
her nothing and literally what did she
get you though she got me like this card
in like chocolate and [ __ ] like that she
drew it she drew like me and a black
flag heart did yeah she got you a Tony
did she stop that route that's your card
and some caramels bro hey I still got
the card yeah man of course you have it
in this special thing under your bed I
dunno that's why I keep them as well
I forgot I got our lunch pail from
Target no oh did she want one yeah for
what for lunch that is a great question
it's very applicable to a lot of Latinos
Berlin you know the King senior can get
Kinson scary she's either I'm guessing
really young or really old
you got like a 47 year old now no I've
done that though really yeah
how did that work that was great I don't
know if I should tell that I had sex
with her at a park in a park with an
older woman
an older woman on the park behind a park
bench on my birthday party see that's
one of the problems of these sanctuary
cities man dude what a cheapskate or she
could get you a hotel room
what's your birthday with that one yeah
that one was crazy my sisters make fun
of me because I'm not even joking she
had one leg shorter than the other
did a little hovel my dad's friend had
something like that yeah yeah I've seen
it before
had one lecture in the other he would
always stand on this one piece of cement
all the time he would take it with him
in his hand and set it down and stand on
it that's see that's so thoughtful me to
be even yeah thank you for not being a
distraction pretend like you didn't see
him set it down and stand yeah he passed
away
yeah he passed me like 30 years ago
hears it appears a guy who has a
question this guy looks did we do the
last did we tell you oh yeah do you do
King or sting not doing anything when
your girl says it's okay oh it's such a
trap dude cuz you know they're gonna
tell their friends they have nothing to
post I guess get them something so they
shut them shut the front and there go
our female listeners here's what I think
you should do embrace your lady get your
girl a little birdbath or something fill
it with chocolate fill it with the
mousse or something chocolate mousse
catch a bird outside and let them
[ __ ] in the apartment but I got
your bird get a dove 26 dollars for a
duck you look up price of local dove get
your girl a dog man get your girl
apparently you guys have birds Asians at
birds guys every every Chinese person
mother has a damn bird that's true take
us into bird ville deals parakeets yeah
why is it there awesome
I [ __ ] hate birds damn 15 dollars for
a nice clean did you see get your girl
two pigeons $15 get her [ __ ] get her
a 12-piece from Buffalo Wild Wings you
know I'm saying little extra crispy
there's a good Valentine's Day called
the before and after package get it that
living bird and that dead bird yeah and
say look my love for you is it's been
here and it'll stay here so it's a
circle before and after just keep
referencing circles and get to Pigeon
yeah get you a pigeon if you can't get
to get a pigeon and put off if you can't
afford a dove get a pigeon and put on
baby powder on his back you get spray
paint that thing yeah oh you can get a
pigeon for six dollars or if you're fast
you can just get a pigeon if you're
really fast there's nothing you need to
clip their wings just spray paint them
white and they can't really fly away and
wet feathers keep it's a life cheap oh
yeah bro around Birds yeah Jim what do
you guys do do you guys eat the animals
at some point you guys is at their
burials how do you guys go actually
buried yeah
my Birds amen you bear your Birds yeah
like do you have like a little coffin
you know we put them in a little shoebox
yeah both of them yeah but a shoebox not
a good idea because kind of big when you
want to bury it yeah but that's what we
did but it shakes in there we won't yeah
both of them they both died at the same
time you know when parakeets died yeah
they died like right after I left there
they're lovebirds they died right after
like old people whoa why you know old
people they've been together for like 70
years one gets the flu the other get to
the flu then one dies in like two days
later the other one dies well that's
like a notebook yeah you know a lot of a
lot of parents and old trick is you get
hamsters name them after the
grandparents and it prompts kids learn
that practice for grandparents died oh
that's a good Matt is a good move it's
like here's pop-pop and here's you know
you know grandma Tiffany or whatever
yeah well they passed away - they're old
and that's gonna happen to your grandma
grandpa yeah and you get to bury them
but yeah that case whisk off and you
guys were serving up up there huh yeah
did the Mexican community with birds die
Craig yeah yeah Barry
do they really that's it y'all take them
back up yeah and then come back we put
the little skeleton on the necklace and
sell it for five bucks pesos that's a
real business man yeah the bone business
is big real big we just have a guy that
would sell he had the erection bone or
the penal bone of a raccoon and he would
bring him to school and sell them call
him boner necklaces no just was I care
you what this raccoon dick
yeah he need [ __ ] some he's opened up
a handful of and have six or seven a
minute pick one out and that guy pricey
around the school he was a B student
he's one of our finer students yeah
price shouldn't be allowed on campus
obese dude I wouldn't call where we went
to school campus that is you price until
I'm over your house
some of the classrooms have wheels on
them okay whatever dude
I remember our science class had a gas
leak at one point of actual gas I mean
bro
what does it say did your high school
have the photo room where was black and
white it was like a purple room you
don't talk about weed weed make your use
like take pictures and then go in there
really I would like the Vela dargah yeah
yeah just look like someone took white
paint and put against the walls is these
kids are just busting knots in there man
there's no cameras it's all like what
you think was gonna happen
damn I want to go to that school yeah we
just have a sick room you would tell
your girl to get sick and you would get
sick and you all go meet up in there
that's dope and it's pretty crazy cuz
soon as a teacher would come and open
the door both different times flew the
bus dude I'm feeling nice today
thank you you look nice dude did you
like a sort of hearing on us yeah bro
you said modeling dude we should I
started using that him and my hair I
don't know dude I just started growing
out and this it's so thick dude oh it
looks really thick especially if I pull
up a picture of some tits on my phone
that your hair gets way thick huh I am
man and 66% of men start losing their
hair by 35,000 I'm 36 I'm 39 I don't
want this to happen hymns boom head
lettuce what's up bro
what up forehand op shop for hair loss
yep for hems comm one shop stop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness oh
you don't say it's Valentine's Day
it sure is have a boys dude usually
you're gonna get that comb out use it
use it on your hair use it on your wing
or beat it against your meat a little
bit yeah fresh out of here get that kick
back further that's a blood and you in
your wand you want pumping Oh imagine
showing up to Valentine's Day with hair
and a weiner perfect gift
tremendous dive into 220 here first
right now you guys get first month free
go to 4 hence calm /ke 80s that's for
hems calm / k 80s that's right
prescription requires an online
consultation with the physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate all for valid only a
prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website full details and
important safety information remember
that's for hams comm / k 80s perfect
do I hear your meat yeah you do you mind
if I use your grill for my meat haha I
do mind bro alright well ladies only
okay dog listen man I love grilling meat
and thank God for a butcher box it ships
a curated selection of the highest
quality meat right to my freaking grill
bro I love that and what I love the best
is all their meat is free of antibiotics
and added hormones and no hooks
sometimes you buy a batch of fish from
somebody they got a couple hooks in the
mouth or they got our arms too much yeah
you know you'll get a bath a bass and
you'll have a little kazoo it yeah you
might get some beef and that's it's
tattooed you know I'm saying I don't
want that dude I found a a cert on there
that they had a jingle bell in it it's
not good man it's not good dude each box
has nine eleven pounds of straight-up
meat for your mouth enough for 24 people
or 12 yet thick friends to no-brainer
it's the best meat shipped right to your
door which means one less trip to the
grocery something what's up
meat for your face with butcher bocce
the highest quality meat around for just
six dollars a meal and they even have
free shipping nationwide meat meat meat
meat meat meat meat everybody meet me
you can get to fleming young's right now
a pack of bacon plus $20 off your first
box when you sign up now at butcher
box.com /ke 80s or use promo code k 80s
at checkout in 3 min Young's boy do get
two free flaming yawns and a pack of
bacon wrap the flaming Young's and the
bacon I'll tell you this if two flaming
Young's show up at my foot the cop gang
gang all right what do you got so we'll
tell Alex we sting that and please don't
shoot your girlfriend here's the next
king yeah Alex yeah we hold partisanship
dude I love live PD just as much as the
next guy but you can't be we don't want
to see you on there yeah
you're stinger sting at number two from
Zach vo Brendan what up Britni
Zach Barrett from new
Jersey here got a cater sting at for you
a Valentine's Day coming up made a
reservation for me and my girl at White
Castle sounds a little weird a lot of
people are doing at these past couple
years reservation was pretty hard to get
can't get our sting it Gang Gang buzz
buzz gangs act
oh that fast I mean it's definitely I
think it's unique sometimes oh here we
go and here's an image right there
did you know it's like it's a thing they
do like candlelit dinners at White
Castle on Valentine well it's gonna file
of that oh no no no that's fast-food it
was kind of fun it's different
says the guy who planned nothing for his
girl Hotel $4.99 right first of all
Rahu's oil roses in a vase what do you
think yeah I mean dude outlook I think
that's nice I think it's a great
marketing idea it looks fun it's cute
your girl won't expect if she thinks
you're just going she's gonna be
depressed but she walks in the door they
got a nice table cause she's still gonna
be she's still gonna be a little
depressed you're still at White Castle
I'm so I'm not huge White Castle fan on
you I'd be down with it fizzes Taco Bell
I like a manageable sandwich man yeah I
like Taco Bell dude really put a nice
gordita or that freakin nacho supreme
with their girl yeah I'm with [ __ ] your
pants there's nothing better you must be
married that sounds like something
coming from a married guy but hey let's
go both use different toilets in the
house oh man it's basically playing
Russian roulette in your pants too good
be Taco Bell you got a race home dude
start living bro you're right start
living a little dog you're right I gotta
get out don't not get to try it man yeah
this is an idea though this is better
than all these [ __ ] are doing he don't
have an idea
bring her to my show because I'm giving
free tickets you're ten you're gonna
hotel you probably work at
yes you do not have nothing I'm so
lonely man I love how chin has on the
typical Asian athletic injury with the
carpal tunnel it is a carpal tunnel
that's the asian ACL they call it carpal
tunnel for typing on a computer come on
bro for nobody chin yeah
ask them if you had I thought he's going
rollerblading I thought your raise it
like a really strong verb like what here
parakeet is getting big yes I thought of
all trees don't mow it up though
chanting forgetting do it do it on both
man I got a bigger one coming in hell
yeah it's that bad it's pretty bad in
here dude nothing's as bad as Nick is
sprouting bird out of his back look at
these two I think we're in the upside
down bro cat and Derick have the
coronavirus nice to have fallen apart I
think I got the carpal tunnel too like
literally cannot feel my index finger if
I squeeze my shoulder it my thumb goes
numb - here we go
look yeah hey this is you guys way of
asking for a raise did it work [ __ ]
act yet going on dude we're in the
upside down man that's where we are
she is dressed like a redneck Nick Nick
is turning into a - can this is the
widest culture we're looking for her I
said we need a Mexican female
even her texts he's like we need Craig
bro Mike you're the worst what is going
on here's the guy in a bathroom sending
us a question not a shot here's our last
Valentine's related Kingdom daughter
code I hit
hey guys dawn from Los Angeles sending a
singing telegram
your girlfriend's work little
Valentine's Day do people still do that
King at her sting it Gang Gang buzz buzz
Gang Gang ah again these are good ideas
ain't nobody doing this I like that yeah
she's nobody's doing it it's like old
timey yeah that's what I'm saying no
one's doing it yeah what do you what do
you like about it
I just bust off the mariachi's homies
but you know and what is Mario I just
bring myself there that's what I'm
saying
yeah can people hire you to [ __ ] I
guess I would definitely I pay $11 zero
against your pill show up and I take my
rings and roll into a [ __ ] into some
Slayer weather ukulele you know why you
gotta go to thong yeah well bully's
right yeah oh yeah later what it's
Valentine's doesn't man thumb but he's
not wearing yeah he does have a diaper
he does have a diaper so i'm say you
show up in a big diaper diaper in those
wings you'll be all ready do we do we
have any get have you posted a video on
instagram you playing the guitar yeah
hit that [ __ ] Nick I think I got one of
me playing Black Sabbath all right or
just Sabbath as they call in your
community oh well looking young man so I
was like did you go to junior high in
the 60s
yeah okay
does that Wesley Snipes in eighth grade
go to video Garth Brooks hmm
that's coming up I was right there go up
yeah
hey poppy take it easy on the chocolates
are
right yeah you want to take a love
I says lover cameras okay I pay 12 bucks
for that [ __ ] was I think it's well I
think 12 man it is good man well I mean
between you two just start a ban or
something man chin sings you play the
guitar you seen you play guitar too
now does chin sing you what do you play
like metal or I play everything metal
country RB RB hibachi do you know any
Asian R&B artist you're looking at it
they call him GART bro yeah you got me
card quick yes we call now look at him
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
show your girl you never
[Music]
[Applause]
some D
Wow what were you at when I was making
that album when I was at station yeah
what are you doing back there bro how's
you gonna produce my album Jane have you
talked about doing American Idol we
talked about remember no I don't the
voice American Idol voice I'm not too
crazy about the kind of dicks but uh
American I don't feel like maybe like I
look at this giant Korean and they go up
then just knock their socks off yeah
Billo weird or the masked singer the
mass singer - oh yeah oh oh no they put
some real weird people on there yeah I
love I love the judges at all uh is that
Beyonce in there like that [ __ ] is not
Beyonce real Slurpees are doing this
show yeah it's always like genuine or
Warren G or some [ __ ] you know it's cool
old-school yeah yeah you just hate it on
genuine and Warren G no not good all I'm
saying is to remind you of genuine good
[ __ ] chin it's a season for love what
about people that don't have somebody on
Thanksgiving I mean yeah they're
starting to pile up so that does it for
qinger sting it next back by popular
demand we have a Valentine's Day themed
round of race my case where people like
and race my case they were loving it we
got a lot of submissions I ended up
doing these because I wanted Valentine's
related ones but people loved it
evidently maybe I shouldn't even address
this but there's some rude dude out
there and there people are saying we I
know root dude I never do do that just
show but I read his book actually his
book is dude have you ever done the show
on shade 45 I never got I did it when I
was doing promotional for a Showtime
he's a great dude people are saying we
jacked the show I had no idea it was it
was a one of our listener submissions
and got our raise my case it rhymes a
JIT I'll check in with him and ask him I
don't feel like we did I know we didn't
jacket yeah yeah for sure I had a little
accident also I don't think he's the
only one where people you gotta get
who's doing the crime yeah so God
surprise we're gonna read a case and we
have to each put in who we feel like
what culture ethnicity did the crime
so PacifiCorp is on specific as we need
to
yeah or country if you can't just pick
up one race here we go man gets prison
for Valentine's Day robbery of bank
where girlfriend worked blank who needed
money to buy his girlfriend an
engagement ring is now headed to federal
prison for help carrying out Valentine's
Day robbery outside the bank where she
worked
he's been sentenced to six and a half
years it took put he's held up twenty
six thousand dollars from a Bradford
National Bank that they were stocking
outside an ATM he drove away in his 2008
Mustang Mexican Mustang passionate
Latino loves his woman can you say his
must thank you - word Mustang
know what it feels like it boosts tanga
[Laughter]
elmo's Tanya give me the details again I
didn't hear it so he really he robbed
the bank
where his girlfriend works for money to
buy her an engagement ring this is why I
did all this when I drove off in a Ford
Mustang that's white white oh yeah so
white I think they were in on it I think
the chick was probably in on it and it
sounds like it was a white guy to me
yeah you know I'm saying why can the I'm
gonna say like Oklahoma Texas area but
here's the thing though if you tell
somebody you tell your girl if you're a
if you're a white guy you tell your girl
okay I'm gonna come in here I'm gonna
rob the bank you need to beat you're
gonna be there like I'm just trying to
think whose gonna go along with that if
you say that to me some dumbass the girl
says she didn't know and she was cleared
of all charges everything had to well
here this might shed some light he was
dropped off at a neighboring City and
took a greyhound back to his
girlfriend's to comfort her
I love greyhound and everybody's on
there I feel like but not Asian so I'm
gonna say it's not Asian because you
it's white black or Mexican on greyhound
do it so this is this is why it all day
I'd say why y'all white Latino you know
I'm gonna go I'll go black I'm white
Oklahoma Mary white for sure
Ramsey [ __ ] was Lebanese dating a
white girl that did not specify but most
likely Lebanon now you don't make sense
yeah that was your next it just clicked
and Craig's it was like the Lebanese are
into that bank robbery kind of the old
Wild Western type of stuff you know
that's also the plot from Ben Affleck's
movie the town movie is it yes great
movie good movie zero zero zero zero no
one scored next one Jesus Christ dude
Valentine's Day lovers were caught on
closed caption TV as they robbed a till
from a jewelry store a pair of luck
struck lovestruck teens share this
romantic moment in front of a TV that
they did not know is recording they
ended up stealing $275 and left cameras
laptops and smartphones that they could
have stolen so where's the lover's
quarrel this is a Romeo and Juliet type
of thing they wanted the jewelry it's
Valentine they wanted the jewelry but
also not a terrible idea I'm going white
I'm going black black I'm gonna go black
too
you said they left cell phones and
laptops everything valuable yeah but I
do don't [ __ ] with love now they don't
it was a 19 year old lay you an 18 year
old jingchou or Chinese that's what was
the first name lay you le i white Li Lu
is a black guy
I thought I was right it's the boil a
Lulu die jiang xiu they Lou Johnson Jane
Chu sounds like a new Copenhagen skull
he set that Jang Jane we're so off no
hands even clay Lu so anybody who scores
here takes it home we got our last one
right a man stole roses from all DS
grocery store that were 1999 for his
girlfriend for Valentine's Day well
wasted white boy a man stole roses that
were worth $19.99 from an oldies grocery
store for Valentine's Day for his
girlfriend I'm gonna switch it up and
say Pakistani Wow
you gonna pieced and all I'm saying what
I'll do all these is prominently usually
a white type of environment in there
it's a good Midwestern grocery store I'm
gonna say white yeah I'm saying white to
sprite happen at maybe Albertsons or
King Soopers this is a white boy all day
to do it white boy with drunk drunk with
love you can do some crazy [ __ ] what
what Craig say white white
he was Pakistani like that girl broke my
heart when I gave her that album some
people haven't gotten over something
broke your heart you think and y'all's
like you think who is somebody hey
everybody said their hearts broke huh
who and nobody wants a shade on them I'm
just sayin who did it who done it
sometimes it just happens one thing you
follow you know you did it to yourself
sometimes you know but just saying who
did it to y'all feel you guys how you
wanna say I broke my own heart a million
times I'm sayin who broke y'all's [ __ ]
you [ __ ] creeps
okay because this is obviously with
jinna's he had your heart broke yeah but
not by a girl that I was dating I had a
crush on my best friend before a long
time ago okay younger and what happened
and she liked me at the time but I
didn't know if she liked me so waited a
year to ask her huh
and what happening you went off to war
yeah that was like my biggest crush ever
and then so she didn't feel the same way
after that and then you can capitalize
but this we became friends still friends
today and if she married now she's
married and do you guys swear to a judge
she's an attorney
oh where I don't say where he's coast
come on bro I I mean there was there was
a senior girl Maggie hide who I really
love to have after as a sophomore but
but yeah then I can't really say she
broke my heart we got really flirty one
night in college as I was gonna happen
but just close I'd go back to this town
sometimes they had a girl that I was in
love with when I was a child and then
something I saw her in college once she
broken up with her boyfriend and we like
hung out a couple times that I was like
too nervous to try and like know if like
she was interested in me I was like like
I'm like I was just like I would just
spent all my money on like new shoes for
that night or whatever and [ __ ] like
I just had still no ability to talk like
no matter how much new shoes I'll put on
this couldn't be like do you anyway
yeah man this chick I I had one head one
chick when I first got to LA she was so
bad of course yeah any dude she wanted I
thought we like in a relationship and
then I saw I was like I'll hang out
tonight she's like oh I can't my girl's
birthday oh my god makes sense and then
I see on TV she was like in stripper
relationship with like some famous dude
how's it go well I don't stand a [ __ ]
chance no struggle city man dead broke
me I can't compete with that
that's right and then when I text about
Jason I call her out he's [ __ ] sweet
I take a page of the TV lights all
around right TMZ or some [ __ ]
I'm like what's up with this and she
goes what did you think was gonna happen
I like oh oh
frozen bro that's ice cold Craig yeah a
girl showed up outside my work right
after we broke up with another dude and
I chased them in the car weird were you
working at Trader Joe's oh yeah how did
you get let go up from there you did I
farted on my manager as a joke and I
filmed it and I put it on Instagram any
went viral and then corporate saw and
they're like get this kid a D oh damn
get him out of here what do you mean get
this advertising guru this marketing
genius you're the only person headliner
that called me you know that oh I was
yeah oh I see if I was all right
oh right happen yeah oh wow yeah that's
here
oh damn do people lose their jobs all
the time and he has no idea of America
works or anything happens she don't get
it but I know it was last year yeah it
was the best thing that ever happened it
should be I tell you story god yeah yeah
sorry you were good to you for a long
time 11 years yeah you're here 11 years
solid bro
well here's like the Gandalf of traitors
do you like the Philip Rivers of Trader
Joe's so I'm just gotta leave man yeah I
know I wanted you I was too big of a
[ __ ] and then and then it happened and
then you element you were guilty for it
cuz you you shout me out you remember
you did a story and you just followed
Craig for behind the scenes Trader Joe's
oh and I was fired like a week or two
later you call me like hey man I have
anything to do with that
oh he blasted it out more yeah but this
was before the gay before the gassing of
the man yeah yeah but still it all
contributes to the hyper like now I got
to put on the show yeah you really that
one go on the manager like a ripped did
he deserve it
yeah funny Oh your friend yeah it's your
friend he laughs he didn't give a [ __ ]
about it but corporate corporate huh my
manager that fired me went to my show
Saturday and then fired me Tuesday like
he was the homie he didn't give a [ __ ]
it was like like a mice and men when
Lenny snuffs out his brother you know he
was like almost crying I was like they
did you what you gotta do yeah they did
you saw yeah let's go remember the last
day did you were you on shift and then
they told you to leave they talked to me
and then they they talked to me I went
back to work and then they they said I
just went back I clocked out and they're
like we'll let you know if you need to
come in tomorrow and then the next
morning I went in and they're waiting at
the door I was like oh [ __ ]
I'm like you guys made me wake up this
early gonna called me you know how but
it was a blessing right it was it my
career start poppin off after that oh
wow Chappelle you've had your heart
broke yeah but a lot of it was mine yeah
did you heard any of his stories a lot
of it was my fault no it seems like I
used to I used to be like they do that
was just like like I didn't even need to
know a girl if I just liked her I just
asked her out immediately because I
thought that's how it worked you know
yeah that's all black guys things it
works and that's why they do so well
with it the girls yeah good brother you
know work for me you wouldn't live a day
in a white man's [ __ ] brain bro it's
so hard to ask a girl out bro yeah
holding her up you know you got ladies
right there that's when you ask about
anyone go out with me you're building
the trust building the trust that trust
man that goes a long ways it'd be funny
oh you don't say oh you know you don't
want to go out with me what what's the
drama girl we're gonna close it out with
debate club she's got one topic ranked
damn boy right here hey guys this is
Christian from LA and I've got something
that you guys can debate what's about a
getaway weekend for Valentine's Day Napa
Mexico wine country or tequila country
thanks guys
gang gang buzz buzz well goddamn baller
since he got some option
we took Keela countries in that Mexico
he said he said why don't work to heal
Napa Mexico tequila or wine oh god
you've been a Napa mmm it's more of an
older vibe you know I'm saying I have
that great what are you looking forward
to Carlos and charlie's brought you
looking for that dude with that whistle
ooh [ __ ] chiropractors break [ __ ]
because I've seen your frog go to Cancun
dude it's disgusting that slide that
shoot you into Bay see the sewer system
margaritas it's the word if you see your
bugs as a slide
it's always somebody every dude in there
has like a turquoise blue shirt on yeah
and then there's foam it's all shot and
it's always like those two girls look
what they're doing aunt Randy pouring
shitty tequila tequila you would use to
[ __ ] start your car bro like fans
yeah it's like tequila in syrup it's
like just horrible [ __ ] and then there's
40 dudes in one and then you walk out of
there and a couple of [ __ ] vatos
straight-up steal all your [ __ ] that's a
night yeah actually does sound pretty
fun because I like boys you can get mug
that a little bit I'll probably go
Mexico maybe yeah I have that fun at
Napa I don't know man it's a mitzvah
Larry right what you'll do it also got
burned down he's a lot of it's Burt
y-yeah nepo is on fire man
a shitload we got burned down I don't
think so dad I think is the other one
what's the other one so yeah Paul nopal
here somewhere
maybe Sonoma maybe non-pressure a bunch
of fire
it was now the fire starting their tubs
laying in order rule oh yeah but county
destroyed more than five thousand six
hundred forty three structures half of
which are hubs fire just should be
alright now should be alright well dude
a lot of that when that soil gets burnt
up that's how they make good crops a lot
of times pop it gets nutrient-rich they
call it circle life yeah mmm it's pro
life circle of life circle of life yeah
tubs fire sounds like a [ __ ] great
name for a thicker porn star sounds like
a great name for a barbecue joint tubs
fire do you get that brisket tubs fire
do barbecues a great thing to take a
lady out for who it is it's kind of
sexual when you deep throat that rib
yeah that beautiful gay man and hit us
up he could take his man out and get
those ribs and put them one by one
yeah sectional brother you get that
sweet sticky sauce over your hand oh
damn boo your finger each other with it
we're gonna need to see you in the
office and I'll be back next week it's
here man it's the seasonal love bro love
is in the air dawg and I think of the
best idea we come up with we just came
up with at the end here take your girl
or guy to a barbecue place man
get that potato salad the cornbread put
a little honey but no matter how many
things you say that are edible it
doesn't make the love between a mini
stronger Brendan I mean done there's a
lot on another element to these no dude
if you sprinkles all about food big boys
unite if you split a full rack of ribs
or so on nothing says I love you like
that dude you could even go to Chili's
yeah you get a chocolate shake full rack
of ribs
put a little bit on my girl used to like
those things from Chile the egg roll
or whatever the Santa Fe egg rolls where
they cut them out of angle so it goes in
your mouth easier damn Brenda yes I
think your girl liked them son I don't
hear the Dexter of snacks over here you
better learn your boy hey maybe it's a
good time to get to know your boys a
little bit better you know Jim let's
tell us something about you we don't
know man how get to know you a little
maybe spend the night with your your
with your friends who's a dude and why
some romantic comedies watch some gold
and girls I'll watch Golden Girls the
other day girls oh honey
god it's so good so good dude impeccable
writing have the homies over have the
bros over Golden Girls Friday night have
the whiskey flowing mmm see what happens
see what happens I know what's gonna
happen everybody's gonna leave it I'm
gonna go to sleep dude which is supposed
to happen
maybe maybe still be I give it a shot
dude what was your question fortune tell
us something new about some something
new by me yeah we're trying to learn
about you Chan it's about love the
Valentine's Day tells you something we
should not but I don't even know where
to start you guys to ask me something
I'll tell you see that's the problem
nobody wants to go on a branch to share
about themselves mm-hmm
tell us something chin I'm trying to
think what's new about me I'm guessing
you guys know mostly everything about me
tell us something from your heart how
things been going with your new
girlfriend uh I think it's since early
January she says it's late January it's
late because we didn't we didn't talk
about actually monogamous commitment
until late January and are you guys
monogamous or you guys woman oh wait I'm
thinking of um polyamorous no no
Mongolian Mongolian yeah yeah yeah but
but but yeah it seems we go how often
are you seeing her she already had plans
to go traveling so we see each other
part like 10 times already
that's it and how many times until like
what what do you guys is there a certain
number of times you're like okay now
this is it we're in this for life or
water whip see it's still freaking
really brand-new so yeah and is my best
friend so it's all so different oh it's
crazy
20 years that's not 20 years yeah I mean
I know I've known for 20 years but best
friends for like you know how nervous
were you to take it over over the friend
zone it's pretty nerve-wracking because
I don't know what's gonna happen
sounds like we're interviewing Steve
Carell and [ __ ] four-year-old yeah
I'm at her tits felt like Sam it wasn't
that nerve-wracking when he took out
that big titty white we had for you I
know yeah you seemed pretty comfortable
that [ __ ] guzzling down that spot for
the day ma'am night did it for the team
have you taken your girl does your girl
senior number in your environment with
Korean barbecue slang that works on your
lips many times oh yeah yeah oh you
girls white no she's Vietnamese Oh
carpal tunnel and some [ __ ] asian girl
bro we got the x-men over chance so
vague about his girl I got a seat you
know if you met her multiple times a CT
Bravo idea I'll see you again this
weekend okay yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
question her up by restaurant oh well
yeah I appreciate it okay Dan what about
Nick is loving the air over in your
relationship what's going on Nick it's
going really well
she was vetted she was here last night
she helped me decorate she's awesome we
went me you and her I went to bull
riding this weekend a staple cider that
was pretty wild
oh yeah the three of you went you were
the third wheel yeah we had some other
friends but yeah it was awesome the bull
riding dude it's amazing
is it looks let me ask you this you
wanna talk about true love yeah for sure
[ __ ] grabbing a rope two bulls nuts
real love it was not it's around his
waist yeah educated so he's bucking no
that's why he's bucking
they would not they do something that's
what does it do oh look there is a guy
tickling him alone his name's Craig
Conan
I got fired from that yeah let me know
about the rodeo the first like 30 Man 3
like dance is crazy know about an hour
mark I go I'm ready to go no it started
to get I just didn't know what was going
on and it was a call that it was like
the it was called iron cowboy where it's
like in the beginning was twenty guys
they all rise and then it goes down and
eight guys and then it goes down to four
and then it goes down to two so towards
the end I mean they're riding every like
to run in each other real hard yeah at
the end sometimes yeah two guys would
come out on each other's just bareback
in each other it's pretty like but it
was amazing bro
it was amazing I could I could see it
getting old if you had shitty seats but
the PBR they took care of us we were
right up in front like bulls were
running right past us it was so cool
yeah I'd be fun to go yeah we got to go
up right for the invite boys right above
the shoot where they let out the let out
the balls we were like five feet away
from it was yeah couple times you got to
be right up above and went sat on the
side the clown that does the middle
stuff he's amazed
yeah real dumbass they like the
Dalmatian of humans you know you say
Dalmatians Dalmatians the kino
Dalmatians are only dogs dumb enough to
run into a house on fire that's why
firefighters [ __ ] with them really yeah
or that's bravery dude depends how you
look at it just like the clown in the
rodeo is it bravery or did you have no
other gig going on it's a good point
regarding the welfare of animals PVR's
policy well let me see literature for
you let me read it from their side I
like the holes of their meteorite boys
are rooted up - some of them are some of
them have been accused yeah are they
riding like the same Bowl
yeah the Bulls going on are on tour as
well so the Bulls have like different
rankings and stuff as the Bulls people
don't even know they essentially draft
which bull they're gonna ride and they
kind of know which ones which I don't
know exactly is it still eight seconds
yeah goal mm-hmm eight seconds but you
get judged also so you need you wanna
you got to ask them style if you're just
holding on oh yeah there's some black
bull riders huh yeah yeah I met a guy
named Evan is four I met another dude
named Larry
govenor Devon it was Devon actually come
on Devon nice on that bull he wasn't
right he had ridden the day before but
he was on their practice swag with her
horn that I would have loved to see that
ad not just you he was bumping
chappelle's makes a to get high yeah
he's the only rider that came out to
lean with it rock genuine my pony yeah
they had some oh one of the riders uh
Jess Lockwood he just he was just on the
this past weekend podcast he came out
and he played our theme song in the
beginning
oh that's cool oh did he do well yeah uh
he got I think fourth he made it to the
second night which was far enough and
he's the 2017 2019 World Champ so he's a
stud he's only 22 years old millionaire
is that young it's pretty you get aged
out around like 35 pretty much but he
still goes yeah he's still kind of a
phenom and also you have to wear helmets
now but if you're born before 1994 you
don't have to wear a helmet so there's a
few out there with just their cowboy hat
you see those rolling wheels the other
guy's got [ __ ] yeah leaders helmet so
it looks like women's softball yeah
cricket helmet like they were weak man I
want that cowboy hat I agree I want that
cow with that gallant cowboy brain dude
if you don't do well yeah I want that
bull brain hell yeah well lover birds
maybe you guys are watching this and
trying to you know figure life out with
your loved one maybe they're doing that
dude we need more love out there though
that's the truth isn't it mm-hmm
speaking of can I pitch a new segment on
air maybe we'll cut this out yeah but
it's been hard to try to get people on
dates actually go out and get them
people we trust anyways how what if we
have people send in their tinder
profiles that pictures they're using and
there's their profiles we help them and
we coach them up yes and then they
update us later mm-hmm the follow-up
mm-hmm
see if they're getting more see if
they're getting more man I think what's
going on here no one's really swiping
right and I go you should take picture
like this or do this on your profile
yeah we don't yeah what could we call it
you think splinter my tinder that's the
only half rhyme but it's close though
we're like something I would think up
and then it's unthinking workshop this
week but send those things did I just
put tinder in the profile that's really
good love you guys man thank you guys
for being here you gonna be a dog some
vague relationship with your stepmother
lastly it was a weightlifter from fresh
angel uh yeah I'll be an Oreo casino
this week I tick is it this one let's
sail from Maui Maui Hawaii February
March 7 I'm jealous dude well at least
you'll know if it goes well I'm excited
man they don't get a lot of stuff over
there on the island you know
no there's get like jo koy and [ __ ]
Gabriel yeah go see a man I'm an Ontario
improv this weekend and then next week
I'm Vancouver for the jfl comedy
festival one night only Friday book
theater and then after out Tacoma
Washington gang man and I got off the
bring Chappelle and Craig out with me to
a show soon that'd be fun man I won't
know that I don't know where we'll do it
but we'll pick a date here sometime soon
be fun get these boys out of here thanks
for coming in the culture corner guys
yeah guys man yeah thank you
gang